about a planet that has no metals right
does not me the moon is an object it has
very few metals I've got enough to build
a spaceship the latest model for how the
moon was formed was that it was a
sideswipe of a mars-sized object in the
very early solar system when it was
dangerous to hang out because things
were still forming and accreting
material and so here's the subjects
science wipes the earth levy sideswiped
us we already dumped our iron into our
core that's where most of the iron in
the earth is it's heavier than
everything else yeah and so so if most
of the iron is there if you think
they're dinosaurs then huh it's Hollow
it's up so once you sideswipe the earth
you're making another body out there out
of stuff that's already pre-filter to
not have metal so the moon is of
interesting kind of place so so the moon
might be part of the earth or it
probably is probably was part of the
earth part of Earth's crust and and and
with all the stuff that was really
delicious going into the middle of the
earth already already when we come back
more of star talk that hasn't quit